you started killing it before you had
kids or did your trajectory start taking
off because like we were like we're not
having kids right until we can pay for
kids right I always thought that was a
[__] because we had so many friends
in stand up who like like even burnt
friends you know like he's one of those
guys as a kid is like a feature act
making a hundred dollars or you know a
show and I was like uh-uh and I wanted
kids
I was the opposite of like a lot of
couples where I was the guy being like I
want kids
and Christina was like
we're gonna have kids on what we make
this is [__] crazy and and I knew
like other Comics who had you know they
had their kids at like 22 and they're
out there doing and I'm like I was like
I mean that was the part that I I didn't
I didn't fight back on that I was like
you know I don't mind
I don't think I feel like you have to be
like doing extraordinarily well to have
kids but I didn't want to be at the
level I was at at the time which is a
feature Act of making a hundred dollars
a show yeah and that is before I pay for
my plane ticket you're like dude so I'm
guessing that the six-year-old is the
younger one no no he's the older oh yeah
cause you've been killing it for a lot
longer than that well actually you know
the he was born we we decided we could
start planning to have a kid after
uh like we could start planning to have
a kid and then he came along you know uh
two like about two years later okay so
like in other words
started to do like I probably could have
been like we could have a kid
2013 2014 it became clear like this
trajectory is going
better like and and like hey we can
start looking to do that and then he was
born at the end of 2015. so it was like
you know it was like solidified like
Okay We're not gonna be like oh my God
how are we gonna pay rent this month
yeah and then we started planning to
have a kid but really he'll be seven
yeah because I I mean the dream of yours
is to do to do comedy like were you
worried that having a kid would like
crush your dreams yes or did it make you
work harder well but both both I think
both happen when you have a kid you
start to go like oh like your immediate
thing is like well I'm no longer cool
right because you're like when you're
out and you're like drinking partying
you're just like this you have no resp
nothing you know I can go to bed at
[__] four in the morning all of a
sudden you go if I have a kid am I gonna
be like a dad comic who's like diapers
you know and like my shit's gonna be
automatically lame like that's your fear
but the other thing that happens I think
for I think it's almost like in our DNA
is like
the second it's like your your your you
know your spouse starts showing and
you're like oh there's a [__] baby
that I'm responsible for you go into
like this like a hunter-gathering yeah
hustle mode where it's like a drive that
you didn't know even existed in you you
know which was just like so focused to
be like I have to provide yeah yeah I
had a guy ask me one time if I you know
I was like 30 and he's like are you you
have kids and he's like a middle eastern
guy and I said
so now dude I still got a lot of stuff I
want to do with my life and he's like
what are you talking about I was like
you know I want to make money and this
and that and he was like so shocked and
he's like in the Middle Eastern culture
the more kids you have the more money
you make it's a good omen yeah there's a
lot of people I still remember Al
Madrigal I was like I'm Madrigal was
telling me I was like I think I was
telling him this was before we were
having him he was like don't you want
kids
because he had kids young too
and or he had his young and and I was
like yeah but you know this and that he
goes it was he was kind of like that he
goes the universe will provide
it's like if you have kids he goes
it it just provides you're gonna be fine
do it do it people used to have kids so
that when they were old elderly that
they would have these kids to take care
of them yeah and then now it's like the
kids are just baggage and burdened and
and the elderly are taking care of their
kids like forever it's called Stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole and if you
go on Amazon and type in Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole and Order
yourself a bottle you'd be really
helping me because right now we're at
ranked number 30 on all of Amazon and if
you buy a bottle we might go up the
ladder and that would mean a lot so
please get on Amazon and buy Stevo's hot
sauce for your butthole yeah
yeah dude